we have triangle ABC here which looks
like a right triangle we know it's a
right triangle because 3 squared plus 4
squared is equal to 5 squared and they
want us to figure out what cosine of 2
times angle ABC is so that's this angle
a b c well we can't immediately evaluate
that but we do know what what the cosine
of angle ABC is we know that the cosine
of angle a b c well cosine is just
adjacent over hypotenuse is going to be
equal to 3/5 and similarly similarly we
know what the sine of angle a b c is
that's opposite over hypotenuse that is
4/5
so if we could break this down into just
cosines of ABC and sines of ABC then
we'll be able to evaluate it and lucky
for us we have a trig identity at our
disposal that does exactly that we know
we know that the cosine of 2 times 2
times an angle is equal to cosine of
that angle squared minus sine of that
angle squared we prove this in other
videos but this becomes very helpful for
us here because now we know that the
cosine I'm going to do this in a
different color now we know that the
cosine of angle a B C is going to be
equal to a sorry the cosine of 2 times
the angle ABC that's what we care about
2 times the angle ABC is going to be
equal to the cosine of angle ABC squared
squared minus sine of the angle
a B C squared a B C squared and we know
what these things are this thing right
over here this thing right over here is
just going to be equal to 3/5 squared
cosine of angle ABC is 3/5 so we're
going to square it and this right over
here is just 4 v squared so it's minus
4/5 squared and so this simplifies to 9
over 25 minus minus 16 over 20
five which is equal to which is equal to
seven over 25 so this thing right over
here is equal to seven
sorry it's negative got to be careful
there 16 is larger than 9 negative
negative 7 over 25 now one thing that
might jump at you is why why did I get a
negative value here when when I when I
doubled the angle here because the
cosine was clearly a positive number and
there you just have to think of the unit
circle which we already know is an
extension is an extension the unit
circle definition of trig functions
which is an extension of the sohcahtoa
definition x-axis y-axis let me draw a
unit circle here my best attempt so
that's our unit circle so this angle
right over here looks like something
like this so it looks like something
like this and so you see its
x-coordinate which is the cosine of that
angle looks positive but then if you
were to double this angle it would take
you out someplace like this it would
take you out someplace like this and
then you see by the unit circle
definition the x-coordinate is now we
are now sitting in the second quadrant
and the x-coordinate can be negative and
that's essentially what happened in this
problem